when it comes to
making a youtube channel isn't it great
when you can get just a little bit of
feedback so that you can learn how to
reach the right audience get more views
and ultimately make a bigger impact in
the world well i'm excited today because
on this show the youtube made simple
show i have my friend dan from vidiq and
we are going to be doing channel reviews
for you uh thanks so much for watching
my name is heather torres and like i
said i have my friend dan here so dan
how you doing hey i'm great how are you
welcome to the youtube made simple show
i was gonna find my bumper but
apparently i don't know what happened to
it so we just went into it what do you
think
i i didn't prepare any kind of song or
dance or anything to replace your bumper
so i do apologize had i known i would
have i would have helped you out there
that would have been that would have
been the best thing for me uh dan's
actually one of the uh creators of the
executive producer actually over at vid
iq
and uh and he is um someone who does
regular channel reviews and actually
video reviews which is such a cool thing
you guys are doing over on the vid iq
channel we are doing an amazing
partnership with fit iq bringing them
over here to the think media crowd so
that we could be doing channel reviews
for you as well but uh dan real quick
what is like one feature you love about
vidiq you don't have to show it now
we're going to show it in a little bit
but but what shots one we could seed for
people about a feature that they would
want uh to be using on vid iq
so if titles are something that you're
struggling with and it is something that
whenever we do channel reviews in
general it is something i see people
often you know if not struggling with
something that they could prove on
improve on a bit
we have a tool that's going to help you
do that i'm going to show it off a
little bit later because i'm really
excited it's one of our newer tools here
at vidiq i am
so over the moon about it and uh it's
really gonna help out a lot of people
it's gonna be amazing well hey if you
would like your channel reviewed here's
all you have to do we have the think
media team inside of the chat if you are
watching live on youtube if you are
inside of our video ranking academy
group or if you're a part of our think
media community all you have to do is
say i want a review drop your link and
the think media team will be putting
those we are not doing them in any order
this is a random selection uh and we
have been gathering different channels
from around the think media community
for the last two days so hopefully your
channel gets reviewed but here's what i
want to encourage you is that if your
channel doesn't get picked this is still
an opportunity for you to hear how we
are critiquing other channels um this is
our opinion based on what we know inside
of youtube of what works well by being
able to review hundreds of channels uh
over the months time and by being able
to coach and train different content
creators um over this fans of over the
span of the last few years so we're
bringing to you the knowledge we have as
content creators ourselves as well as
coach and trainers inside of the youtube
space so dan if you're ready to get
started let's bring up your first review
and uh and i'm excited yeah uh
absolutely so this is jesse evans
they're about to hit 100 subscribers so
congratulations early congratulations to
you
and the reason i picked this channel is
because one of the comments they made
was that they are and i don't have a
verbatim but they basically said they're
getting a lot more traction from their
shorts right now and they're kind of
wondering if they should be pivoting
their strategy to just doing shorts and
we see this a lot with youtube shorts uh
so if you watched the uh mr beast
conversation from vidcon that he he
interviewed someone from youtube and
they talked about this a little bit
basically the way i'm going off on a
tangent right now before i look at the
actual channel basically youtube when
shorts first came out they saw that the
youtube algorithm was like hey people
all of a sudden really like short videos
huh and it wasn't doing a very good job
of recommending long-form videos after
that point so
for now youtube has decoupled the shorts
and long-form algorithms so if somebody
finds your shorts
they're not necessarily going to get
pushed your long-form videos youtube is
working on this according to that
interview but
for the time being that is why you're
seeing this trend of sometimes you get
over 2 000 views on a short and then you
have a long form video that gets four
views and you're not really sure it's
like wait a minute i'm building up this
audience i'm gaining
notoriety here and i'm not getting where
i want to be so
that's why that's happening so the
reason i tell you this is because if you
would like to still do shorts and long
form videos it looks like you're
covering the same subject matter which
is good if you want to still do that on
the same channel you absolutely can what
i would recommend first though is
focus on these two things separately in
terms of titles and thumbnails you
really want to be focused on that for
your long-form videos when it comes to
shorts it's kind of a different strategy
you want that first couple of seconds of
your short to be your primary focus then
title and you can't really do anything
about the thumbnail because it's a short
but basically for shorts think of it
this way
your thumbnail
is the first couple of seconds that's
because people are scrolling through
this in a different feed you go over
here
you click on the shorts button
we didn't i didn't select this you know
it's just telling me what i'm going to
watch and i scroll over to the next one
so the thumbnail is this right here this
is a very intriguing video this dog
getting dragged across the lawn uh you
know this is the thumbnail
this is the thumbnail so it's a
different experience not gonna hit back
a bunch of times it's a different
experience when you're doing youtube
shorts so that's your strategy there but
this is your thumbnail on on your latest
long form video and it doesn't really
tell us anything about what we're going
to get right we have you kind of sitting
in your car
back to work after a long vacation
what's next i kind of feel like the
what's next part
is the part you could have led within
the title in the thumbnail instead of
saying back from vacation think of it
this way i'm like i'm new to your
channel i've never seen you before
so
saying you're back from vacation i don't
even know who you are or what's going on
yet right so instead i would have
flipped this completely and i would have
made the picture of your video the cool
thing you're going to be doing next
right maybe you just mean for your
channel but let's just hypothesize for a
minute maybe you were on vacation and
you picked up a new hobby right and so
you're thinking oh my gosh i cannot wait
to like put this on my youtube channel
so now you have a different title and
the thumbnail because now you're talking
about flying drones right or whatever
this new hobby might be and now it's a
totally different video and then once
you get into the video you introduce the
concept of flying the drones and
whatever but it goes back to vlog form
and you're like yeah i was on vacation
and i i found this this place and they
were teaching people how to like fly
drones and getting into the hobby and oh
my goodness like this is the coolest
thing ever you know so now you're
telling the story so it can still kind
of be the same video with the different
intro but yeah that's what we mean when
we say title and thumbnail because it's
a way different beast when you're trying
to get recommended in home and search
and everywhere else on youtube uh shorts
totally different and uh i think there's
more flexibility for showing just uh
really cool
crazy stuff like we have
what i assume is you sitting in the back
of a an aircraft carrier
i don't know much about planes sorry uh
you're sitting in the back of a plane
here though like it looks like you get a
lot of really cool exclusive clips that
people can't get anywhere else perfect
for shorts when you're trying to do the
storytelling vlog style content great
for long form videos heather i've talked
for like 20 minutes i feel like is there
anything you wanted to add
that was uh amazing and i think people
don't even understand the difference
sometimes i was i was doing a coaching
call yesterday with a group of our boot
campers
inside of vra and i was shocked i was
like oh people don't even know that you
don't actually need thumbnails on shorts
or that you know your thumbnail actually
matters it really does matter and i i
think that was an excellent review you
know one thing that i was wondering
about this channel though dan was what's
the niche like what are they actually uh
who are they trying to reach um and i i
kind of got it but i
i wasn't quite sure and so i feel like
you know that first that first initial
when you hit the page you want to know
what the niche is about so let us know
in the comments what's your niche to
your channel and is it clear when
someone lands on your page i definitely
knew it was something about the military
but i was like who's this for and what
kind of content could i what's the value
i can expect from a channel like this
absolutely like one thing that we're not
gonna you're not gonna see viewers do
we're gonna do it because we're very
curious but you're not gonna see general
viewers coming into your about section
to double check what your channel is
about they're only gonna get that
context from the videos that you're
making so when i see that you're trying
to help people understand the career
opportunities and benefits i'm imagining
a way different channel vlogs where
you're talking about coming back from
vacation don't seem to fit that right
instead it should be like you know
instructional videos and and how to's
and different things that are centered
around the military like you know what
to expect when you're going into
recruitment and what different fields in
the within the military should you be
looking at when you're thinking about
different careers you know like how much
planning should people do are there any
tools out there that can help them with
this planning all of these things are
your long-form videos i still think you
totally have room for the shorts that
you're doing as well on the same channel
because it's all military related
but that's what i'd be thinking about
when you're you're considering long form
and short form content and what that all
looks like on one channel
yeah and you know i feel like that
especially in the reviews that we're
doing dan that's a consistent question
we get should i be doing long form
should i be doing short form and you
know garyvee just spoke at our
conference growth video live and that
question came to him and he was like
it's both and it's everything it's
content it's not which one it's how do
how can i or how should i do both and i
think one conversation i love to open up
with people especially about short form
content is it's not about doing
the shorts right like so i'm looking at
other channels we're gonna review and
people are doing shorts it's about how
you're doing them it's about the story
you're telling within a very short
period of time it's about uh the amount
of changes that are happening it's the
it's how you're grasping your audience
and bringing them in and those are
skills that people have to learn because
it's different than when you're creating
those long form pieces of content yes
100 shorts
it has a lot of fantastic uses and it
can definitely grow a channel but i
think the the biggest mistake i'm seeing
channels make is not
putting themselves in the shoes of a
viewer who is literally scrolling on
their phone and once i did that once i
went on to tiktok and youtube and i
started playing with their different
platforms and seeing how content was
surfaced
that was the best way to put myself in
their shoes and so when i see someone
making a tutorial video that would be
great you know in search for example
i
you know i look at that i'm like this
should have been a long form video
because no one is looking for the answer
to this question if they stumble upon it
in the short shelf
yes definitely hey if you would like to
um if you would like to ask a question
to myself or dan during this channel
review all you have to do is just do uh
four question marks before and after
that shows us that it's a question
versus just all the conversations that
are happening in the chat there we want
to make sure we're mixing it up with
some channel reviews as well as some q a
time um and i'm excited because we had a
lot of different channel submissions dan
that were over a thousand subscribers
and that makes me so excited because it
means that people are putting in the
time they're putting in the effort
they're putting in the work not that if
you're not over a thousand but just the
idea that we're starting to see um more
and more content creators really going
all in with their content and that is
true definitely for monzo media who
submitted for a review manzo media um is
doing different types of tech uh
tutorials as well as making sure that
he's sharing the free and affordable
solution so when i think about what
makes you different in the space that
you are in this line right here is a
great line monzo media it's showing me
that you're helping people with free and
affordable solutions so even though the
audience that you're trying to reach
with the content that you have you are
doing uh you're doing software tutorials
to tech gear reviews and um and it looks
like you're really doing a fabulous job
with honing in on what we say is writing
the influence and the influence is
actually in your videos the luminar as
well as i saw you doing a lot of canva
canvas seems to be some of your larger
viewed videos which makes sense right
it's a free app that you can have um
your number one video you made a year
ago about canvas stop motion if i were
to recommend a video you should make
next monzo media it would be success
leaves clues so make a part two you
could probably do this again there may
be a another feature that you could add
on to there and this might also be a
great short that you could do um that
could allow people to just instantly see
stop motion is something that's movement
and so that would be uh maybe an option
for you as well um i did see that you
did the review of the canon m50 you know
think media we love the canon m50 and
we've done a ton of tutorials so great
job jumping on that trend um i would say
one of the pieces of feedback i would
give is probably the consistency in your
thumbnails i'm definitely noticing more
now um the consistency you're using the
logo which is great because that is
influence surfing that instantly shows
exactly what you're doing and i'm seeing
more consistency in the uh current
thumbnails versus the past thumbnail so
mondo media i can tell you've been
studying you've been studying your vra
modules he's one of our video ranking
academy members that i can tell that
he's been putting in the work um for
what he's doing and wanted to say great
job on having a place for someone to go
right here is your link you could even
upgrade this uh top
channel banner to have a sentence here
that says would you like to connect with
me would or i know i was looking at some
of the services that you do
and uh trying to figure out if you are
um doing this like actually
for hire business or if it really is
just a youtube business so i would say
not necessarily review of your
youtube channel that's really doing well
but a review channel of when i clicked
over to go to your website i wasn't sure
what i was still getting it felt like a
reiteration of what was on your youtube
channel so if you are going to be making
some updates to your business monzo
media i would say this website of just
what what are my options what do i go to
what am i getting what can i buy from
you that would be a big part of it and i
wanted to see what was trending over
here on your uh page and this is a
really good feature that they that
dan
this is a really great feature that vid
iq helps you to see which ones have the
highest velocity per hour dan can you
break this down for a for the people of
why this is an important feature of vid
iq
so it's really great for creators who
are you know i i use this in the context
of let's say i have a video idea
and i want to see okay have other
channels that i normally follow in my
space like covering this and then if it
so happens that not only do they cover
it but it's in this section i know i'm
probably on to something because this is
basically showing people
the videos that are getting views
consistently right now regardless of
their age we have a video in there from
two years ago getting some views every
hour and you have a video from five days
ago that's also getting uh you know the
majority of views per hour out of this
selection we're looking at so from a
research standpoint this is a fantastic
tool if you're not if you're not looking
in your own analytics and you're on the
front page of your channel this is a
good again a good clue for you uh
obviously with your analytics uh i'm
talking about manzan in particular here
for your analytics you have way more uh
insights within your youtube studio but
just from what we can see on the surface
this is telling us quite a bit about
videos that you know you might want to
look into especially the older ones and
maybe update a little bit uh the ones
from obviously a few days ago are going
to be getting you know you know carrying
a lot of the current views per hour
you're getting your channel but
of course the ones from months ago and
years ago you can really consider like
maybe it's time to update that a little
bit
well that would be the conclusion of
that review dan right now we have uh a
really great feature with vid iq where
you can actually get 30 days free i'm
trying to find my a little button there
um you get 30 days free trial of vid iq
plan we actually we get this question a
lot people are like should i use this or
should i use this and we are always
saying you should use vid iq because
it's actually been the the software
we've used to help grow our channel to
over 2 million subscribers um and
reaching millions of people every single
month and we use it every day uh inside
of it's just part of our process now
because of all the features all the
analytics that go into um into creating
a well-versed youtube channel so you can
get 30 days free actually let me know in
the comments right now do you what plan
do you have a vid iq what plan do you
have a vid iq you can actually get the
boost plan for 30 days to try that out
with which has some different features
but what's cool dan is the vidiq has so
many free features there's so many free
features we're going to talk about those
um as we go through today's reviews but
who do you have up next dan
so our next uh pick here is
kombucha corral i think i'm saying that
right they got 10 subscribers but
they're off to a really strong start on
youtube they're about six months ago did
they begin their youtube journey i would
say by now you have quite a bit of
videos with varying amounts of views
nothing i can't see anything that's
broken 100 views quite yet
so still some good data points here
though because we see videos here 45
views root beer kombucha
uh let's see i thought i saw another one
this one's in the 30s aqua vita kombucha
uh so there are some i'd be looking at
again if you're if you're talking about
doubling down on different videos uh but
ultimately i think what's going to help
you is doing some research
in this space in general so what what i
want to do right now is just type in
maybe we'll do that root beer
all right and so
you want to rank for this you want to
rank whenever someone's looking for
this beverage you want to be one of the
first results now you are right now and
it could be because not a lot of people
are covering this but it also could be
because i'm on your channel so youtube
is just kind of like you know giving me
that favoritism of you right now but
look down here just under your video
this is one of the top ranking videos
one million views from three years ago
root beer recipe from scratch i know
it's not kombucha but uh
you know comparing just these two
thumbnails for a second of reviewing uh
a beverage for example
the creator of this
particular thumbnail decided not to
really put themselves in it too much uh
every time i put my mouse on it it
starts moving sorry uh they are blurred
out in the background and they are
really trying to make the root beer like
the star of the show
you can be testing out maybe a similar
style where you're still in there but
you've blurred out everything except the
beverage itself uh there's different
things you could be doing i think with
your thumbnails that could help you
stand out more i would definitely look
into getting rid of the black bars
uh on the side having crap like that's
kind of strange uh especially for a
youtube thumbnail let's look at just
let's just say you want to rank for just
kombucha because that seems to be what
the channel is about
so there's a beginner's guide to
fermentation there's a lot of how to
make and then the benefits interesting
interesting a quick start guide to
homemade
it's interesting how many diy channels
come up
from this so what if we type in
best kombucha
don't ever drink this kombucha
that's a good title yep there's a test
from a good mythical morning they tested
out different ones uh that could be an
interesting concept for you i know it's
two years old and it's good mythical
morning so they have they're well
established on youtube but have you ever
considered taking three or four
and maybe doing like a blind taste test
or a top five video or something like
that uh the best kombucha to buy
so
this is where i would be going now it
took me three different searches to kind
of find content that looked similar to
the content on the channel we were
looking at right
that's what you want to be doing when
you're coming up with video ideas if if
the first search doesn't yield any
results and it's not fitting with the
vibe that you're going for on your
channel then keep doing different things
to try and find okay
what kind of content i know someone else
has made content like this on youtube
like where can i find it and if if it's
difficult to find what does that tell me
or if you find it finally after several
searches and you're like oh i really got
to get into this you know rating system
here to start standing out is that
something you want to do if it is you
have a great lead here if it's not
though you need to be rethinking about
you know what what is it what is it that
you're trying to do on youtube uh but
where i think this channel
is for lack of a better term
going wrong right now and i don't think
you're doing anything wrong it's just a
learning process
it's
it's not being i guess descriptive
enough with their titles
um
or
you're putting the brand
in in the title a brand that no one's
really looking for you know what i mean
better booch kombucha
is anyone really like typing in the
brand name of this stuff or are you
going to be the one to kind of tell them
like hey this is x or y this is great or
this is bad uh and then the other thing
i'd be doing is while while you're
thinking of that
give your opinion a little bit in the
title and the thumbnail like give us a
tease of
how this is gonna go for us like if we
click on this video are we going to get
like so like your face here kind of
tells a story right now on on this
thumbnail we're looking at you you look
unsure the perils of kombucha addiction
oh okay that's that's not about the okay
got it different type of video but
you're you're already using different
facial expressions to kind of convey
this emotion so if you were to
exaggerate that even more and you want
to review
one of these products you could be
holding it and looking disgusted or
super excited and then the title is
should you buy
you know x or
why i hate x or something to that effect
so so good dan um we've got some
questions that came in i thought this
one was a really interesting one just
notified said how do i stay on the side
of good click bait
versus bad click bait what's your advice
on that for just notified i have a video
on this and uh it's i i have some i have
some feelings about clickbait it does
look like that just notified is in the
right
mindset here because
there is in my opinion good and bad
clickbait um
my thing always has been
as long as your video is delivering on a
promise in the title and thumbnail if
there if it is delivering on it in your
unique way that you deliver on things
and i'll get to that in a second then
you are on the side of good clickbait if
you are straight up lying to people in
titles and thumbnails because you know
you're going to get more clicks if you
say something that's just blasphemous
then
you're on the wrong side a good example
of this is i don't have it in front of
me there's a mr beast video where he was
challenging his friends to break break
into a bank vault okay when you watch
the video it's very very clear that this
is not a real bank that it's not a real
vault that it was all built by his set
designers and
his friends weren't breaking any laws or
no and no one was getting hurt in that
regard right right so could you argue he
was on the wrong side of clickbait but
my argument is if mr beast says
this is a bank vault
and his friends are breaking into it
because he's told them you are breaking
into this
i'm not going to open the door for you
then the title and the thumbnail aren't
it's not clickbait you know and
people who are new to his channel might
be upset i wanted to watch people break
into a real bank how am i supposed to
know how to do this if no one's gonna
make a real tutorial on how to bring
into a bank mr beast jeez
eventually though as they watch more mr
beast videos if they happen to stick
around they seem kind of angry
they will
come to realize that this is the this is
the thing on this channel right they're
they're doing these challenges so he's
going he made a chocolate factory was it
a real chocolate factory producing
actual chocolate products
no he happens to have a chocolate
product but that was not the factory it
was made in at least i sure hope it
wasn't because it was been disgusting
but
that's that's kind of hopefully that
kind of gives you the idea of good and
bad clickbait that's my thoughts on it
yeah i i love that i think that um
you always want your three t's to align
your topic your title and your thumbnail
and your job is to align those three
things that are enticing enough that
someone would want to click on them so
though so to me if you are in integrity
with those three things aligning then
it's not actually click bait it's
actually just good marketing so if it's
not aligning then you are out of
integrity with what you're asking people
to do and you don't want to build
distrust with your audience you want to
build trust with your audience and going
back to even mr beast the reason that mr
beast is mr beast is because
he has these wild claims that he backs
up like gets stuck on an island then you
know and he puts people on that you know
go yeah like all those so so it doesn't
mean that you cannot
make wild claims you just have to back
up the claim with those other pieces so
i hope that brings some clarity for you
dan i'm gonna review this channel and as
i do that why don't you get ready to
share with the think media family um
just some of the cool features that vid
iq has to offer right now and i know we
do have a lot of new people to youtube
why would they want to be
using a tool like vidiq so i'm going to
share
our next
review and i'm excited for cheryl
cheryl's doing fitness and um she's also
incorporating it's called mind body
faith and there's a couple key things
that i wanted to point out um for what
she's doing number one congratulations
on 3 000 subscribers i can tell you've
been working at this for about two years
which is really great to see that you
also have a business built around this
too so great job uh cheryl i can see
that you've been building but i wanted
to bring this up um for people to
actually see you know when people say i
just don't know what the next videos i
should make that i could really get
views on and so i want to just take you
behind the scenes a little into
heather's mind of how i would do this um
just really literally two seconds
looking at your page here's the videos i
would make if cheryl you were like i'm
gonna go on vacation heather to tahiti
and i need you to make videos for me on
my channel okay well what would i make i
don't know this niche i'm not really
sure but what videos would i make and
the first thing i do is again success
leaves clues so when i come over to your
channel cheryl what i'm seeing first off
is this great
great
thumbnail yoga versus stretching huh
well let's do a little bit of
investigation so what's the difference
between between yoga exercise and
stretching so here's what i did charles
i went up here to the youtube search bar
and i just typed in yoga versus
and now i've got yoga versus pilates
yoga versus the gym yoga versus
meditation yoga versus exercise you did
this one yoga versus stretching yoga
versus weight loss i now have all of
these videos i don't know maybe you can
maybe you can interview someone that's
yoga versus tai chi if you don't know
tai chi or kung fu um but i lit i just
typed this in yoga verses and i'm seeing
all of these new video ideas that can
come up so those would be some of the
next videos that i would make another uh
feature that i saw is this word here and
um i'm sure this is like a style of yoga
gentle yoga for fibroid pain
and you did it in 15 minutes great job
on that it came out eight days ago and
already has 2 000 subscribers so here's
what i did i was like well what other
gentle yoga is there gentle
yoga for
beginners seniors back pain low back
pain uh bigger bodies so you don't need
that one but you you could do that one
sore muscles neck and shoulder you could
just do a whole series on gentle yoga
for all of these different ones so when
i think about what are the videos that
are going to help you stand out
this is what i'm seeing right away as
two very important
videos i also saw this i thought this
was a really great uh angle
on your style of content you said mental
health meditation for black women 10
minutes i would also make a 20 minute
version a 30 minute version a 5 minute
version and now you have four more
videos that you could be making that you
see is resonating with your audience so
that would be my channel review for you
cheryl congratulations on building this
and i hope that helps you thank you so
much for being a part of our community
dan why should people
use vid iq
so you were just looking at a channel
that is covering fitness and a lot of
yoga and things like that so the feature
i'm going to show you i'm going to go
ahead and use that as like an example so
if we want to pull up my screen here
this is our new ai title recommendations
tool now it lives in a couple places
right now i'm on app.vidiq.com and i
like using it here because you don't
have to edit a video to like play around
with the title generator just play with
it to your heart's content but it does
exist while you're uploading your videos
on youtube and in those editing features
you'll see it pop up at the bottom what
you'll want to do is if you have it iq
installed be sure you authenticate your
channel all that fun stuff chrome
firefox browsers uh so
i'm going to just type in the word yoga
let's just give it almost nothing here
okay i'm like i have a yoga video or i
want to make a yoga video and i just
need to think of some good title ideas
get title ideas
this will generate
a whole bunch of ideas with whatever
context you give it so yoga for
beginners make a good start with these
tips five advanced yoga poses to help
you balance your lifestyle three simple
and easy moves to help you relax in five
minutes yoga what is it what is it not
five reasons why yoga is the ultimate
wellness activity
now
the channel we were looking at was doing
more specific types of yoga so we can we
can type in
gentle yoga and see what comes up from
that gentle yoga for beginners it's not
what you expect it to be
seven gentle yoga poses to help you
de-stress so we have a number and then
gentle yoga poses and then what's the
benefit it's gonna help you de-stress or
it's gonna help you with a certain
chronic issue that you're having so
even if you don't like the titles as is
you can still you know reinvent these
but again if you like the titles you can
hit copy and use this on your video
i love using it to generate ideas but of
course if you've made a video and you're
like i just don't know if i've come up
with the best title you can put in the
keywords that you want to rank for and
see what happens so uh
trying to think of other examples now so
like i've
let's see iphone 13
review have a boring title right
iphone 13 refurbished iphone review oh
interesting so maybe maybe you can
review apple's refurbished products just
straight up iphone 13 review thanks
title generator uh apple or sorry iphone
x review slim but does it hold up iphone
13 review appetizing not exciting so
title generator is playing around with
opinions as well in your titles and
these are going to help you generate way
more engaging way more interesting
titles if this is an area that you are
struggling with it's one of our newest
tools and if you're a boost user you can
get as many titles as you want but even
if you have just our free tools you can
use this to limited capacity so
that is that is it heather that's my
favorite
vidiq tool ever i
just used this tool yesterday i was
recording a podcast and we were talking
about personal branding and i was like
oh i just wonder and i was you know
going off myself and i was like oh you
know what title generator duh
so i went in there typed in personal
branding i got i i also kept hitting
generate new recommendations and so i
think i got like 14
different ones all together at towards
the end of my title generating and uh
sent it to the team and i was like i'm
not gonna just make one video about
personal branding i now have four
different short pieces of content that i
want to make i now have two pieces of uh
content that i want to make that i want
to interview someone about like just
generating the title sparked more in me
about just that one topic and um that's
what i want people to use this for you
know uh figuring out what videos you
should be making for your audience when
you know what your keywords are when you
know what topic people want more on the
title generator guys i've been doing
titles for about 10 years in terms of
marketing there's not been a tool that's
been so helpful to me than this ai title
generator so i want to encourage you
that if you've not used it yet do it on
your titles and here's a really good
tool too
if you have some videos that you know
should be performing well but your
titles are kind of uh
take those titles
put it into here and level up your title
on those videos you can change titles on
youtube to help increase the
reachability of those you can really
increase um the uh the amount of views
that video gets because you're going
deeper into the psychology of what
someone wants and also what youtube
needs in the algorithm to understand
what you're doing so uh this is a good
question dan is this for hashtags two
i'm confused keywords is that the same
thing uh when you are uh inside of your
metadata which is a great fancy word to
say the things wrapped around your video
to help the algorithm know what it's
about
hashtags and tags and keywords they're
all kind of different right so
hashtags are generally used in your
descriptions you can put them in titles
as well
youtube to this day in my own opinion
hasn't done enough with hashtags to make
them worth worrying about but if you if
you search for a hashtag on youtube
there are pages that pop up with all the
different videos that have used it but
no one's really searching for hashtags
on youtube but no one's really as far as
i'm aware no one's using youtube search
in that way
so i would i always advise to pick a few
hashtags that like maybe one that
represents your channel and a couple
that represent the content you've made
and you can only i think you can only
put three right in the description
before they're no longer like clickable
so
pick three hashtags and put them in your
description
the tag section is totally different you
would put keywords and keyword phrases
in there that you want your videos to
rank for um
youtube recently has said like hey these
are great for misspellings so common
misspellings if you feel like people are
accidentally typing um
you know vid iq but they're hitting the
l key instead of the i you know maybe
you could put that in there so different
different things you can use it you can
use it for that as well uh and then just
phrases that you feel like people are
typing into search but the the biggest
the biggest draw is going to be the
title and then the description um and
though when we say keywords we're often
just
referring to the different keywords and
keyword phrases that you would sprinkle
throughout your description and that you
would use your title so you want your
title to be keyword heavy so iphone 13
review i would consider a keyword or a
keyword phrase and that would be what i
want to rank for i want people who type
in iphone 13 review regardless of what
else i've attached to that title to my
for my my video number one
so
that's when we say hopefully that was
helpful i feel like i rambled a lot but
hopefully that explained it
it did to me um and i love this one
barry says i use the title generator for
both blog and youtube videos very super
smart um i use the title generator for
my uh i can i share a hack dan can i
share a hack yeah um for what we do here
at think media so we've started to do a
lot more of the short form content i'm
doing it in batches so i'm sitting down
one time
literally just changing my jacket as you
can see that's about all i'm doing
but um this these three proven ways to
make money on youtube in 2022 that was
from vid iq thanks dan for that uh 7 000
views um four tips to starting a youtube
channel in 2022 thanks for those 7 000
views dan vidiq helped me with that so
i'm just literally answering these
questions um and we're getting views
because i'm just pulling up the title
the quickest way to create videos on
youtube that came from vid iq guys i'm
not some super genius when it comes to
titles and i'm just answering that
question within 30 seconds um so this is
how we're using it for our short form
content as well as our long form content
so i love to see that that is so cool
i'm so glad that everyone's finding like
creative ways to use it outside of
youtube too that's really cool yeah
blogs is a great one too um pinterest
posts i've seen people using it for
those types of things so really great
all right i'm going to pick this channel
dan if you want to grab uh maybe two
more and uh and we can help those in the
audience if you have a question for
heather or dan you can drop that inside
of the chat but let me know what's been
an aha moment so far from this live
stream um if you didn't know we do these
uh once uh two times a a month here on
think media but dan you guys are doing
these regularly over on vid iq talk
about some of the streams you guys do to
help the content creators yeah so
tuesdays and wednesdays tuesdays we do
something similar to what we're doing
now which is channel uh channel audits
we call them channel reviews same same
deal we pick your channels and randomly
and we just kind of go through the
different things that we're seeing we
put we could have a wide variety of
channels and then wednesdays we're we're
trying wednesdays are my stream
technically and i want to i keep wanting
to try new things so
uh i decided to try video reviews so
currently we're doing that with
wednesdays and very similar what we're
doing now uh we actually click on the
videos and we we focus way less than the
titles and the thumbnails because you
can get that on tuesday we focus on how
are people in terms of production value
in that first 30 seconds are they
holding our attention in the first
couple of seconds some channels we're
pausing right away and going nope
you can't you know the the audio is this
or
robot voice or whatever it might be that
we you know we see as a mistake and we
want people to you know grow and improve
um so yeah that's that's uh those are
the two streams we do every week amazing
you can join dan and the whole that iq
there's a whole crew now over at vid iq
um it's a really great community and
they're really helping content creators
um and also we're in partnership with
them we are giving away a 30 days free
trial of that iq paid boost plan so if
you don't have that already you can go
to
vidiq.com forward slash think and that's
how uh you can get that i would love to
know your aha moments and i would love
if you've not yet liked this video on
whatever platform you're watching it on
i know we've got our vra students in
here we this is live streaming over on
our youtube channel as well as on our
facebook page can you like this video
give it a thumbs up if you like seeing
channel reviews like this uh here and i
would love to know your aha moment uh
because that to me is great showing that
the education we're providing for free
here uh is helping you and just notified
said i'm addicted to channel review
streams yes that is great put that my
aha moment so i know exactly what it is
um we've got beginning of short
the thumbnail beginning of short is the
thumbnail okay come on heather basic
english so
thanks for that one all right my review
uh next up is going to be smart money
bro smart money row congratulations on
reaching over that 1 000 subscribers
we're gonna get those views up so that
you can get monetized and actually start
making money off of youtube um but i see
here congratulations on already setting
up your one-on-one coaching with the
smartphone bro uh so i love this hey
content creators do you have a way that
someone could pay you
if they like your content do you have a
way that someone could pay you if they
like your content smart money bro
definitely has that set up um great job
on building out
uh your about page you are helping
ordinary people be extraordinary with
their money and or their real estate now
here are some of the critiques that i
see right off the bat um when it comes
to youtube specifically and dan i'm sure
you're seeing the same thing i am when
it comes to the facial expressions
of the videos um when you are making
thumbnails like this uh you've got to
bring the expression to the thumbnail or
don't even put your face on it at all so
you don't actually have to have your
face on your thumbnail and i think this
is a shift for a lot of people dan
because they actually do think that
every thumbnail has to have them on it i
know vid iq you guys don't have every
thumbnail with your face on it right
no we we certain things we find uh it
works it works better to not have our
face in the thumbnail by the way vid iq
is is slacking they're in the chat like
whoever's running the vidiq account
right now is not doing their their job
so
they're they're you're bugging me
um
so
for example
rob is well known when it comes to the
vidiq channel but i am not as known so i
opt not always to put my face in the
thumbnails
and as a test like i want to see like if
i if i hide me you know they're going to
see me when they click on the video but
if i hide me in the thumbnail is that
going to change things and i feel like
it does
but what's also interesting is
you know you have more room on the
canvas to get your message across
because sometimes i feel like people
feel like they have to put their face
and so now you've taken like a third of
your thumbnail and sectioned it off just
for you sometimes half in the case of
this creator and that's very common you
know
you're you've taken the thumbnail and
you've made it so okay half of it's
dedicated to me so now i have this much
space to get my point across and
sometimes that works because your facial
expression sells it sometimes it doesn't
i would say like you said for this
channel it doesn't seem like they always
need their face on there
yeah and and really um steady facial
expressions so if you are going to put
your face on there um you've got to
bring you know you've got to bring the
energy when it comes to it because you
know you're selling yourself you're you
want people to click on it you want
people to
you want there has to be some emotion
there has to be some some draw
to why someone would want to click on
your video when i go to some of your
most
uh popular videos i'm getting a sense of
the type of things that you are really
good at um and so that to me was like
you you have a section eight video here
i'm sure there is a lot of content you
could talk about section eight and when
i think about my friend um let me show
you my friend uh pace morby when i think
about my friend pace morby
ace morby uh has a youtube channel and
he's got 8 million views on his youtube
channel he's making all kinds of content
on here but he specializes in wholesale
and sub 2 real estate and i think this
goes for even financial channels this
goes for real estate type channels this
goes for um coaching channels you have
to define what makes you different
because if you're talking about
everything then you're a generalist you
want to become someone that is a
specific
expert in something especially when it
comes um to youtube you know putting
your content out on youtube so when i go
through here um how to make an extra 500
this week from home that is a very
different um type of video then section
8 is good for tenants so i want you to
decide
who are you trying to reach because
those two videos that are working very
well for you they're actually bringing
in
possibly the wrong people if you have
two videos like this that are doing a
great job but this one is definitely
focused towards how to make money from
home but this one is definitely focused
towards section 8 is good for tenants
and landlords you might be uh
cannibalizing your audience your content
because you're not yet clear on what
you're teaching so are you teaching
finance are you teaching real estate and
i understand that those two things can
overlap obviously as you are making
money from real estate but that would be
something that i would really go deeper
on because when i read about your about
section
you're saying how to help ordinary
people with their money and or
their real estate and when we start
seeing the ands dan is when all of a
sudden
red flags go off and we're you know the
beep beep
those are the warning signs you've got
to make your channel about one thing
first and then you can start talking
about other things so i want you to pick
smart money bro because you still have
an opportunity to really hit the market
here um strong with what you're teaching
and when i see that you're already
teaching financial coaching then i would
maybe go deeper in that way if that's
the way that you would like to make
money online so that would be my review
for you congratulations on what you're
doing dan who do you have next
so i have another short channel here uh
because this one really intrigued me
brand it like a pro ooh good
yeah a channel that is specifically
about branding i presume uh i speaking
of i do like their branding uh and they
are doing primarily short form content
we do see
some other videos popping up in here
where they've kind of made thumb okay so
they've made thumbnails but it looks
like this one's going to be a wide
screen this one maybe
maybe a shoe now i'm curious hold on
it is it is a short it's gray on the
sides okay so yeah
testing out thumbnails on shorts
now
the main thing i wanted to
talk to with this creator about was just
the the pitch of their shorts because
like we talked about earlier
depending on what you're doing in shorts
certain things might work better in long
form style so
uh if you're doing really like if you're
doing really tutorial heavy content
while that can work in shorts and i've
seen it work in shorts i also suggest
like coupling that with a long-form
video on your channel uh you're going to
help break into the monetization program
with this content as it gets more views
and stuff you're going to be exposing
yourself to a wider audience for the
folks who are searching for this
in the youtube search bar rather than
you hoping that they stumble upon it in
the shorts feed uh so let's just kind of
look here so you got to be careful when
branding does your brand have a mission
statement steps to successful branding
so you're covering a lot of different
topics here i want to click on one of
these and just kind of see when when i
stumble upon this i've just watched a
video about a puppy and then i watched a
video about somebody cleaning up trash
on the side of the highway i'm in the
shorts feed i'm scrolling i'm scrolling
i find this
so what to avoid when branding was the
pitch of the video i i don't have my
sound on so i don't think anyone heard
that but the pitch of the video is like
what to avoid when branding uh now
my ask to you is you know thinking about
who this content is for
i
i do feel like this is very very very
niche
for youtube shorts
that's my biggest concern for you
because this that's the other thing it
doesn't have to be about tutorial versus
not tutorial depending on who your
content is for if it doesn't have a more
mass appeal you have to ask yourself
maybe you know maybe i really want to
target people the right way so search
might be a better place for me
widescreen videos that could get
recommended in the home feed might be a
better place for me and i feel like for
this creator that might be something to
test
never just take what i say and just run
with that and like that's
that's the only way to do it test
test test test always um but that's
that's my first big uh thing that i
would tell you now if you want to keep
doing shorts
you could be giving your education from
a different perspective my idea for this
creator would be what if
you use shorts to show off
brands that are bad at branding right so
if you see someone who's made a logo and
it to you and your professional opinion
just doesn't look good
what if that was your short and so now
imagine the logo for the company pops up
on the screen when you scroll through
and it's like look at x company with
their logo like who made this you know
and
or if you want to you know talk about
why
the twitter logo is is so you know
ingenious right there's some logos that
have a lot of like tricks to them right
they they represent a lot of different
things like the amazon logo with the
arrow the a to z like you could be
pointing out different things and logos
that are really really clever if you
want to go the more positive route i
know i went negative there for a second
but the more positive route would be to
praise brands for doing it right now
does that appeal to the same audience
you're going for yeah it teaches lessons
about branding right and does it have a
more mass appeal yes if you're looking
at logos and branding of recognizable
companies now you're reaching a much
wider audience oh my gosh i never knew
that about the coca-cola logo
so
that those were some angles i wanted you
to consider the next time you're you're
making shorts because you've been kind
of making you've been putting out a lot
of content and for content that gets up
there in age
like 13 days ago we see one that broke a
thousand views but that it's so far and
few between
that i i do worry that you might be
spinning your wheels at this point
because of the sheer amount of videos
you're making on these topics so those
were some of my ideal ideas for you uh i
do hope you found that helpful really
really great and i want to end this on
this question dan
how do you make shorts go viral so
you're you're making shorts but how do
you make them go viral and let's first
define what viral is because i think
that word alone especially for new
content creators um or if you i'm just
teasing this out like crazy so
uh if um the way i view viral might be
different so let's talk about it dan how
do you make shorts go viral and what is
viral
so to me
viral
would be like it's in the context of
your own channel if you generally get
100 views and a video breaks out and
gets 10 000 views is that viral in in
the grand scheme of things and you know
does everybody in the world suddenly
expose this content no no 10 000 people
were but for you that is a viral success
so i would be thinking about
that
level of viral and that's going to help
you just put it in perspective it takes
the pressure off like i saw a minecraft
channel like i see the minecraft avatars
there i saw a minecraft channel that got
a million views on their shorts i want a
million views on my shorts
you know
let's let's settle on the next milestone
before jumping 10 milestones ahead right
so that's the first thing i would say
that's what viral is to me um curious if
you have a different opinion there
heather yeah i think um there's a
marketing term called tam the total
addressable market and so what might be
viral in the minecraft community may not
be viral in the homestead community
right like the idea of what virality
numbers could even be
really has to do with the total
addressable market how many people are
actually interested in that thing and so
how do you make shorts go viral so that
would be what viral is um and so i love
how you said that dan and and uh think
media take this to heart
take the pressure off yourself of trying
to go viral you know one of the things
we teach here at think media is that
this is not
a diet this is a lifestyle and so when
you become really great at making
content you don't become great at making
content overnight you have to be putting
in the reps just like if you were moving
from uh you know trying to lose 20
pounds it's not a diet you have to adapt
your lifestyle and so when it comes to
virality it's not actually trying to go
viral every time you post a video here's
what it should be about i want to help
people with this content i want this
content to be the best that i could have
made i want this content to lead
somewhere where do you want them to go
what do you want them to do and i want
this content to actually be worth
someone's time to watch and i think if
you take those four things into
consideration when you're making content
you will have what we call breakout
videos so we we don't even use the word
viral in in what we talk about at think
media with our team because we just want
videos that break out right it's like
it's like baseball i'm really hitting
this hard because i want people to
really hear this because i get this
question a lot it's like baseball
obviously they want to hit a grand slam
every time but you know what actually
wins games base hits
that's what wins games base hits having
a better batting average
is better than not having a good average
and then hitting one home run that's not
actually the best baseball players and
so we want the same thing to be on
youtube we want you to have a great
batting average not just one grand slam
home run grand slam home run same thing
right um so i hope that helps just
putting into context but uh
two minutes dan how do you make a short
or any video go viral
so
in the context of shorts i i would first
make yourself a student
of
shorts make yourself a student of the
type of shorts that you want to create
spend time on tick tock as well because
what's working over there is going to
work on youtube because what we're
talking about is just human nature right
what what gets you to stop scrolling it
doesn't matter what platform you're on
what gets you whether you're on
instagram tic talk or youtube to stop
scrolling when you see a real or a
tick-tock or a short pop-up
and think about that really think about
the next time you're scrolling through
and you stop and you enjoy something you
think maybe i want to hit the like
button stop yourself there and go why
did i enjoy this
and then watch it again and again and
again and like was it the intro was it
the way they did the colors like what
what caught my eye like when we clicked
on the shorts uh earlier we saw a dog
being dragged through the grass they
were trying to walk their dog it did not
want to walk did they say did they hold
their phone up in front of their face
and go hey guys today i'm gonna try
walking my dog my dog hates walks and
then you know then he's no
no they didn't it's just a short they
didn't have time to intro it just pull
the you know just pull the leash
that that's what's going to it's it's
really hard to explain it's not an easy
question answer but at the same time
when you put in that context it's the
easiest question to answer make it
interesting you know start start with
the intrigue but also while you're
making that video ask yourself the
question
if somebody is finding this out in the
wild they have no idea who i am they
have no idea where this content came
from if it would like originate in a
live stream for example if they have no
context at all does this make sense to
somebody if i run up to somebody on the
street go look at my video does it make
sense to them when they look at it the
whole experience of you running up to
them will not make sense and i don't
recommend that but
if if they were okay with that would
would the video make sense
really really great dan thank you so
much for
coming on co-hosting the uh youtube made
simple channel reviews with me it's
always so good to have my vid iq family
over here on the think media channel dan
where can people find you and what
should they do next if they don't
already have vid iq
so uh thank you for having me first of
all i really really appreciate it look
forward to this all the time uh
you can find us over the vidiq channel
uh i'm addicted to being live so i'm
just going to jump over there they're
having a stream rate and i'm just going
to jump in i'm just i'm just going to go
interrupt them because i think it'll be
fun um the next thing you should be
doing is if you're interested in our
tools our products things like that you
should absolutely go to the link down
below vidiq.com think get yourself that
30 day free trial it's take advantage of
that something you've not done before um
or if if you've you know if it's been a
while maybe you took advantage of that
already and you're like ah but it's been
forever it looks like they have some new
tools get our free tools we have so many
tools that you can use for absolutely
free try before you buy and uh yeah it's
been a pleasure
so good well thank you so much dan and
if you would like to see other channel
reviews just like this you can click or
tap the screen right now and if you want
to see another interview that we've done
here on the podcast you can click or tap
the screen we'll catch you in the next
video bye think fam